حفنه صغيره منه كفيله بقتل بعض البشر
يلقبهما تجرا على تجربته بالشبح او حاصد
الارواح بمدغه واحده حرائق ونيران تشتعل
داخل فمك لكنه هناك من يتلذذ بتناوله انه
فلفل
اقوى انواع الفلفل الحار على الاطلاق
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
رائق ونيران تشتعل داخل الفم بمجرد تذوق
قضمه واحده من هذه الحبه الحمراء الصغيره
صراخ ودموع واختناق ونوبات صداع يسببها
تناول فلفل كيرولاينر الفلفل الاكثر حراره
على وجه الارض
فلفل حار هجين من فصيله
يزرع بشكل رئيسي في ولايه كارولاين
الجنوبيه في الولايات المتحده تصل درجه
حرارته الى نحو مليونين ومئتي الف وحده
خاصه بقياس حراره الفلفل
اقرب المنافسين لفلفل كارولا هو فلفل
ترينيداد موروكا او العقرب وتصل حرارته
الى مليوني وحده سكوفيلد اضافه الى فلفل
ناجا او الافعى وتصل حرارته الى مليون
وحده سكوفل المرعب في الامر ان مفعول فلفل
قد يتجاوز حرقه الفم بكثير ليصل الى
الوفاه في بعض الاحيان عام 2018
التهمه رجل يبلغ من العمر 34 عاما فاصيب
بالام حاده في الراس والرقبه ونوبات صداع
شديده استمرت عده ايام تلك النوبات يطلق
عليها الصداع الرعدي وتمثل حاله الطوارئ
صحيه لانها ربما تكون اشاره على وجود نزيف
في المخ او ربما جلطه حيث ان الكابسيسن
وهي الماده الفعاله في الفلفل الحار يمكن
ان تسبب ضيق الشرايين
يتعين ان ياخذ الناس حذرهم لدى تناول
الفلفل الحار اذا عانوا من تلك الاعراض
يجب ان يحصلوا على رعايه طبيه فوريه
رغم كل الحراره الكبيره فضلا عن المخاطر
الصحيه المحتمله يتلذذ البعض في تناول
اصناف مختلفه من هذا الفلفل في هذا المطعم
بالعاصمه الاردنيه عمان يضع القائمون عليه
لافته تحذيريه اضافه الى شهاده اخلاء
مسؤوليه يتعين على الزبائن توقيعها قبل
تناول وجباتهم الحاره التجربه
فلما سمعت عن كبده وشطه اجيت جربته فصراحه
يمكن مره الميل بعيدها
الامر لا يتوقف عند هذا الحد فهناك
مسابقات تجره وارقام قياسيه تحطم في تناول
فلفل كيرولايناريبر الاجواء هنا مشتعله
لكنها تبقى اقل اشتعالا من هذه الافواه
الملتهبه
[تصفيق]
ياكل واحد من كل اربعه اشخاص على هذا
الكوكب الفلفل الحار يوميا ويعد الانسان
الكائن الوحيد الذي يستمتع به حيث تتجنب
الحيوانات تناوله عاده ورغم عدم وجود
تفسير دقيق لعشق مليارات البشر الماكولات
الحاره يرى بعض علماء النفس ان الامر هو
نوع من الماسوشيتي الحميده اي متعه
الاثاره بطريقه مشابهه لمتعه ركوب
الافعوانيه مثلا ماذا عنكم هل انتم من
عشاق الطعام الحار وهل تجرؤون على تجربه
كيرولاينر